the Fertile hills between Florence and
Siena home to some of the world's
best-known vineyards
this is Chianti one of Italy's renowned
wine regions
grev a population 4,000 is the center
for the wine trade and other local
products like mushrooms and cheese this
is a place that appreciates tradition
breve is a place where time is never
rushed our challenge and our duty is to
try to maintain the soul the essence the
specialness of Grevy in Chianti and all
the other slow cities Grove A's mayor
and mayor's from three other Italian
cities created the slow city's lead
their mission to keep their hometowns
from moving into the fast lane out of
that sprang the slow food movement it's
simple preserve the pleasures of good
living good food family and friends now
the movement has gone international
more than 66,000 members worldwide
it's very nice to live here because we
have a nice atmosphere we have a nice
landscapes and so when you have nice
things to see a nice place to live in
it's very easy Salvatore a Toscana left
the past life
she ran an american-style restaurant
Lawrence where he spent his days digging
up burgers
five years ago he dumped his french fry
and moved to breve where he's opened a
new restaurant it means taking the time
finding the rhythm that lets you live
more calmly in a lot of ways starting of
course with what you eat
in the mountains of vestroia in northern
Tuscany generations of farmers have
produced a pecorino cheese they say is
one of a country made from the raw milk
of black sheep the cheese is hand molded
twice a day
but this tradition had been dying out
until slow-food stepped in with a
campaign to organize the farmers and
promote the cheese both are making a
comeback put that's in the 30th that
it's brought us a kind of notoriety not
everyone knew about our product the
project is getting us noticed the
Singapore's Macao from Singapore to
Macau in New York and Rome you always
find the same pizza the same hamburgers
slow food doesn't want this slow food
wants the specialness of every product
to be respected
grev a is not trying to escape the
modern world it's a city that is simply
enjoying itself doing its best to take
it slow